you
[Music]
so hello and welcome everyone it's my
great pleasure to host the Rachel
Cummings Rachel is a professor at the
industrial engineering department in
Georgia Tech she works on differential
privacy and game theory and connections
between the two she is a recipient of
multiple awards assignments Berkeley
Graduate research fellowship award the
Emory
doctor'll price award and best paper
award it is car and so she's going to
tell us about differential privacy for
growing databases thank you thanks guys
I'm very excited to be here I was told
this was a very casual environment and
so feel free to like jump in and ask
questions it's much more important that
you understand that I get through all
that in the slides and they also have a
mild I'm have have a mild like I'm
speech impairment and so if I pause
briefly I promise and not just a
daydreaming and during my talk so I'll
talk about doing work with some
colleagues and collaborators Sarah creel
is a former Georgia Tech grad student
now faculty at University of Richmond
and Kevin and our current grad students
at Georgia Tech and I'll be talking
today about like how we can extend
privacy guarantees to the case where our
database is gonna be growing and
changing over time what do I mean by
that so the olden days
data science meant that you like collect
data once and you analyze it and then
you go home in the world ends and so
this look like things like the M is set
census I get new data every 10 years
maybe like a survey that was mailed out
and you had to like first build a survey
maila
out and then wait like three months to
get the responses back or if you're a
very fancy maybe there's a call center
and you had to like train these people
to call and ask like very specific
questions and they collected data and
you analyze it at the end
data science looks very different it
happens online and it's and it's
changing all the time and we're now
doing things like collecting everyone's
health information anders and their
tweets and there's social behavior
online and maps and so we now have have
to do like a continuous analysis of a
growing database because we're acquiring
more data over time we also can't wait
until we like you know accumulate all
the tweets in the world and then decide
what's trending but in fact I have to
tell you all the time on the current
database the current tweets or the
current like I'd like I trends so we
need new analysis tools for the case of
growing databases but in these examples
it's also like highly sensitive data and
so this is your health information and
this is your like social data and you're
like a GPS data and so we also need some
kind of privacy guarantees because we're
now collecting much more sensitive much
more personal information about people
I'm so some background differential
privacy was defined in 2006 by to work
makes sharing a seaman Smith and it
informally bounds the maximum amount the
one person's data can change the output
of some computation performed on a very
large database formerly it says this so
an algorithm M the maps from an end to
Pullip
and so think of that as as a data
collected from like n different people
just my arbitrary range is prima tries
epsilon differential private if it's a
case of for all neighboring databases so
the same except for one person's data
I'm going to output approximately the
same thing on these two neighboring
databases and by approximately I mean
we're gonna compare the probability that
I output anything s and it should be and
the probability is that I produce s
should be M multiplicatively close up to
this e to the epsilon factor and so in
pictures it looks like this I have some
blue database and they produce some blue
curve over there
and I'm then gonna change person eyes
data from Ti to being ti Prime and and
then gonna get the red curve instead and
so these things are close and so I can
then bound the impact of person eyes
data and so really I'm saying if you
provide your data or or if you don't if
you're truthful or if you lie I'm gonna
learn about the same thing anyways and
so your portion of my data set has a
very small effect on the thing that I
learned at the end of the day and so
think of this set set s as like the
collection of all bad outcomes maybe
this is like I'm going to analyze their
health data to decide insurance rates
and decide if like smoking causes lung
cancer like saying well like you know
your insurance price is going to rise so
the same probability if you share your
data versus if you don't and so think of
this as as like the collection of all
like bad outcomes and they happen as a
result of the analysis of this data and
in saying and I'm saying those things
are gonna happen with about the same
probability and anyways and so I'm
really not relying on your data it's
also very strong like worst-case
guarantee and so it's worst case over
all pairs of neighboring databases and
overall collections of have like
possible bad outcomes and so this is
very very strong any questions so far
there's a couple of nice properties that
make differential privacy desirable as a
tool for designing algorithms so first
its robust to post-processing and so if
I have some difference your private
algorithm m and they then apply any
other function to it the post-processing
is still going to have the same
differential privacy guarantee and so
really this says no adversary can take
can take the output of my differential
private algorithm go in a corner think
really hard run some additional
computations on it and then like
reverse-engineer my data and so I'm
promising no adversary can break this
privacy guarantee and to note and so
note also there's no requirements on the
computational power of the adversary but
rather this is a like mmm information
theoretic guarantee it also composes
adaptively and so this says if I have if
I have K different private private
mechanisms and their each epsilon I
differentially we private then if I were
to compose all K of these then I can
just add up my absalon's and that gives
me my final privacy guarantee and so
really if I want to run a whole bunch of
different Upsilon differential private
computations on my same data the epsilon
czar just gonna add up there's more
advanced versions of this that I won't
include today for example this still
holds if you choose these m eyes
adaptively how you first run m1 and see
the output of that and then decide on
which m2 to run next and this still
holds has also here there's also a like
a relaxation of this where you have an
additional Delta Delta term over here of
some like additive slack and so I then
have this like applicative parameter
Epsilon
and that I had this like additive slack
Delta I won't talk about it today but
there'll be some like brief mentions in
passing about this like epsilon Delta
version and so just keep in mind that's
what the epsilon Delta is is there's
this like additive Delta term here and
so there's a more advanced composition
version for the Epsilon's don't just set
up but in fact it looks like the l2 norm
or the absalon's
and so you get so you get like much
better composition and the epsilon you
have to have this like additive loss in
the Delta so you can do better than the
business but this is sort of like the
most simple version okay so so back to
my differential privacy is great so
because we have this parameterize
privacy notion I can now move smoothly
between informational extremes I no
longer have to say that an either gonna
give you data or not but I can actually
like quantify how much information am i
leaking through my epsilon by performing
this particular computation at my data
set how we saw that a has feels like a
post processing and these composition
guarantees which mean if you want to
design differential private algorithms
then you only have to reason and about
these like various simple subroutines
that are private and then you can just
like add up the epsilon Xin your entire
larger more complicated algorithm and
it's being used in practice and in
theory it's being used here thanks guys
for inviting me and so it's being used
in practice by Apple Google Microsoft
uber and these Census Bureau and we now
have like a rich background of like a
differential private algorithms that are
both private and have some usefulness
guaranteed so it seems great
the problem is nearly every
that's been done operates on a static
database and so we have great tools for
a static database we have virtually
nothing for a growing database previous
work only allowed us to count bits in a
stream and that's although we could do
privately so today we're going to do a
lot more stuff privately hana growing
database first we're gonna see a very
specific tool for answering adaptive for
like answering adaptive honey or queries
and that's gonna be based on a private
on the algorithm private little packet
of weights and we'll see why it can't
just extend naturally to the growing
database case will show how to improve
it to make it work and then we'll talk
about like much more like a
general-purpose results in how we can
extend existing accuracy and privacy
guarantees in the static case into the
growing environment and finally this is
sort of like a first paper on this topic
and I think that there's lots of other
types of growth to be analyzed and so
I'll talk more at the end about how
about questions raised by this work any
more question right jump in cool ok so
the first part is on private
multiplicative ways for growing data
databases and this is a great algorithm
to answer exponentially many adaptively
chosen queries and so that's like a
super powerful tool but it doesn't
naturally extend to grained databases
just one slide of preliminaries first so
for this part we're gonna store our
database as a histogram and so think of
a database has a has a vector where the
ice entry is the fraction of the entries
in the database that are of data type I
and so there's like capital and total
types of data and I'm just going to
count how many of each type have have I
seen and so for example if this is like
a binary data I want to count like do
you have a disease
not and there's two types and you can
either have a plus or minus and that's
it and so then this is gonna be a tuple
maybe I want to count account like you
know how many people of each age there
are and so then this is maybe like 120
if I'm being generous things like that
and so we're going to be thinking in
this case about just answering linear
queries where each query is gonna also
be described as a vector and it will
assign a weight to each to each type of
data hey X I we're going to assume that
these weights are bounded between 0 & 1
an important thing that's gonna follow
us through the through the talk is the
sensitivity have a real-valued query
which is just going to be the maximum
change in that query f if I were to
change one person's data and so I'm
gonna say what's the worst case over all
neighboring databases how much can I
change the valuable of this function f
and for these and for these query
classes we're going to have like I'm
Delta F be of size 1 over n for a
database of size n finally we want
algorithms that are going to be accurate
and our accuracy notion is of this
alpha-beta accuracy and so we'll say
that an algorithm M is going to be alpha
beta accurate with respect to a query
class F and so here think of maybe like
the class of all m then your queries if
it's a case therefore any database F I'm
going to have like I'm highly accurate
answers produced by my by my algorithm
for all queries in that class with high
probability
your definition in your query so if
you're not normalizing but I still use
that you are - you are she's not
yes I am no what is he yeah there was
this one yeah yes yes yeah
in fact is important here that it is
normalize so yes thank you yeah and this
is a slight abuse of um rotation here
this is sort of like imagining that I
can apply this query into the output
produced by my mechanism and so just
like a grant me that for the ease of
them rotation here okay so here's a pmw
algorithm it's by Hart Ross Blum in 2010
and answers exponentially many
adaptively chosen linear queries and it
works by maintaining a a public
histogram why this sort of like contains
all the information that we know so far
each point in the algorithm and so these
like new queries are going to arrive
online and the algorithm is first going
to decide his my why so far pretty good
at providing an answer to this query and
if the answer is yes then it will say
and it will say that it's easy and I can
just output f of Y and I don't have to
like touch my true database X and if not
that classifies F is hard and it will
output a like um always the answer to F
and will then like I'm update Y
accordingly and the key idea here is a
you only get significant privacy loss in
the hard queries because for these ones
I really just have to like check his my
answer on why close to what my answer is
on the true database and so I'm not
really like using much information about
my database and this works by showing
that well as time goes on this Y is
going to like a converged to your true X
and so I'm gonna see fewer and fewer
hard queries over time and so therefore
I'm
getting very much privacy loss overall
in pictures here's how this works I have
a public histogram why say that it
starts being um uniform and I've been
going to get a query and say for example
this is my query f1 and here is the
vector corresponding to this f1 and
imagine that my and imagine that like
this query over predicts and so the
value is larger on a Y than it is on X
and so this is going to be classified as
hard query and I'm then just going to
like down weight Y prime is according to
this vector and so for example because
because my loss and one and two for two
large I'm going to like I decrease the
weight place on on on the types of data
pointed to here's how they're lower and
in been going to read normalize and that
pushes more weight on to for the
opposite could happen for a heart hard
query
maybe my f1 look like this and I've been
under predicted when then gonna do the
same will plug it away it's update to
adjust my like a public histogram why
and how the algorithm works by just like
taking in queries over time and then if
it ever sees a heart hard query then it
performs this update and the guarantee
have the static algorithm is as follows
and it takes in a like I'm database a
query class privacy privacy perimeter
accuracy parameters and and a size of a
database and it is on epsilon
differentiate private and and it's also
accurate for 4k queries and for this
alpha house okay the important thing to
note is that there is this like one
third power because that's what's going
to change in our
and our like extension of Oh actually
know what to give us huh yeah donation
athlete vacuum helper is the additive
yeah yeah and it relies on this like a
potential argument that says will
eventually my Y is going to converge to
my X and so these things are going to be
very close and so I have to show that
that then this entropy start slow and it
goes down fast as they as they answer
more hard queries and it's also bounded
below and so it's like a standard
potential argument and so for the fixed
database case it looks like this it
starts the most log n by the way the
algorithm initializes things had and it
like initializes Y to easy on the
uniform histogram and so starts a log
and we can and we can like also quantify
as a function of the learning rate how
quickly how quickly did this potential
decrease and it turns out that for every
hard query it goes down by this term
helpful squared over four if you tune
the optimal learning rate and if ended
below by by m0
so great what happens if the database is
growing did these things still hold oh
one thing okay good and so we have it
most and so this case we have at most
for log n over alpha squared hard hard
queries and then just by like I'm
composition I can then guarantee that my
epsilon loss is gonna be instead of n
epsilon privacy laws you're only getting
log and epsilon crescents yes yeah yeah
yeah
this n is the size of the database is
the size of the data universe but if you
look at this like I just like alpha
squared term here
oh yes yeah yeah good yeah yeah
competition that will give you okay
epsilon but now you are saying okay yes
yes exactly so this is why it allows you
to answer exponentially many queries
because because one thing L hits hits
one then you're not really learning
things anymore and so I can now answer
and so I can now have a K that is like
an exponential in my n before my
accuracy loss gets too large yeah
and the real crux of this is because you
don't actually answer every everyone is
just because you like only answer a
small number of them in fact it's the
property of my tablet integrate upgrade
our yeah yeah
okay so this all works for a static the
database is very powerful this is an
amazing algorithm but it doesn't work if
you allow more data to arrive so we have
this part of our database of size n for
this picture and then let's say new data
arrived
well my entropy can go back up as they
add more entries and in fact in fact
that's going to be the major problem we
can still show that it's going to go
down a significant amount for these hard
hard query and it's still bounded below
but the size of this change can be a
really big can be a really big big deal
and in fact it can look like this so as
your database doubles in size you can
have this log have this log capital n
over alpha growth which it's going to be
fairly yeah so there's almost no hard
courage because the public databases has
revealed the private database so all the
secrets are out there's no more secret
stuff because that's one way of looking
at it the other way of looking at it is
that I have found a database this shares
the same statistical properties is my
original database but may or may not be
exactly the same and so it enables you
to answer all the queries in your query
classes that you care about but I'm also
not guaranteeing that it's the same
database
maybe different yeah yeah
and then the entropy I mean the entropy
looked at the X I mean the entropy is
small in the databases are really very
very similar yeah yeah yeah it's no fact
at a certain point when you had once
you've had this many hard queries that
have been answered Hana Hana static
database then you can say I don't even
need to run this anymore but I know that
with high probability my like a public
histogram Y is going to be good at like
answering all the queries maybe him am I
like in mid class and so I can then just
like publish that as I'm in thick data
and then that's just like a post
processing and so because that's just
like post processing at the output of
summed to front a private algorithm then
it's still like a difference your
private itself okay so this growth can
be really large and so that's a bad
thing I mean sort of like the bank
reasoning updated or um yes good
question so so here we're saying the
queers are going to arrive online and
the data points can arrive online and
here we're showing here's a really bad
case where I have like use up a bunch of
my hard queries and then a whole bunch
of new data arrived and it's I'm gonna
take me a whole bunch of more hard hard
ones to get back to the same place that
I was before and because you start with
the entropy higher than it higher than
it was before even because of this alpha
term this means that you can have like
an unbounded number of hard queries so
it can no longer make the same claim
because they have this bounded hard
query budget that at some point I'm
going to be done and I can say that I'm
accurate
and so like really think of yeah yeah so
because you're only looking at EDD
whereas if I allow so much implicit URL
that it shouldn't be a problem yes
depending on like if I only care about
one plus epsilon multiplicative either
plus like whatever because you're saying
some point acquaintance are too many
then the Instagram can completely change
you can basically start all over again
yeah yeah
and so like what happens is that is it
like imagine if there's like a starting
point in the middle I mean imagine if we
like a projective space of all of all I
can't you take databases on to some like
I'm 2d plane and so I started in the
middle at a uniform distribution but the
Truax is like over here and so I'm gonna
slowly move over here to the process of
a lot of hard
queries and then and then some adversary
can like dramatically change my my axe
to be like way over here and so I'm
gonna have to do like a whole bunch of
more hard queries more than it even took
to get there in the first place and so
this can sort of like go back and forth
basically forever and so we fix it by
saying actually like really as soon as I
get new data I'm gonna read I'm gonna
read I'm gonna re wait my why to be
closer to the uniform and so like in
this example instead of being like over
here and then have X move over here and
I have to have a whole bunch of hard
queries has my database grew that
dramatically I'm gonna like
automatically shift back to center or
close-ish and then start moving through
hard queries from there and so we're
saying I'm gonna take I'm gonna take my
current Y and I'm gonna renormalize
imagine that I have like n points and I
gain one and again one point that's new
then I'm gonna say
then we're gonna re normalize so we now
this like I'm a convex combination
between my old Y and the uniform
distribution and this then bow
um do you like a potential growth in my
my entropy and so we're good again and
so main result of doing this is that is
it for our like p.m. WG we're here G is
for growing is really the exact same
thing as pmw only we do this updates as
soon as we receive new data entries and
because the update doesn't depend on the
content of the data they don't incur any
privacy loss from doing that that's the
size of the data universe that's the
size of the starting database and so it
says that I can be epsilon differentiate
private it's alpha beta hacker it for
this for this alpha at each time T and
before I had a fixed had a fixed at a
fixed query budget I could only answer K
questions but I can now answer this
thing that is growing exponentially in
time and so is my database grows I can
now answer exponentially more queries by
harnessing by harnessing the new data
that have arrived
and there's also asymptotically no loss
and accuracy compared to the static case
we have a constant that's too ugly to
print so there is like a content loss
but but you know asymptotically is fine
and in the paper we extend this into
epsilon Delta differential privacy and
through these like stronger composition
guarantees we can effect improve alpha
at some small loss in our privacy to the
public Instagram that's completely
invariant of what the new data is
because you're only answering like count
where these are things where the sense
these have found it like me so yes okay
yeah yeah and it's actually critical
that the update doesn't depend on the
data because if you looked at the data
and then decided how to update now count
toward your privacy budget algorithm
description at least it seemed like the
only source of randomness was coming in
from the query stream that I mean the
kinds of queries that were coming to the
algorithm algorithm suppose it doesn't
state yes I lied a little bit there
in fact I'll point out where but that's
a great catch so so this part I said how
you add noise here which is that you
provide and know is the answer to the
query if it's hard the part that I
thought that I lied about is that you
actually have to decide in a
privacy-preserving way whether a query
is going to be easy or hard and so you
have to do this randomly and so you're
gonna have some loss because there's
going to be some queries that you say
they're easy and then you just publish
that go wildly wrong answer but that's a
low probability event and it's also
going to be times we have a query that
you're being that you're correct on
you're gonna burn through your hard
query budget incorrectly but again
that's a little probability event it was
a it was a differential private truth
tell that to our president okay next
next slide all right so that was all
that I had for this how they're like any
questions on this before I move on what
is bizarre and this and this King
exponential squared would be this is
what you lose extra that's one that's
what we gain
at Strathmore yeah
the loss is really Justin as constant
and you gain the ability to answer more
queries and the trick the original
results from cocaine exponent
exponential screw yeah I mean there's
definitely some toast yeah I think the
constant is nice mole yeah it's like
eight or something like that yeah yeah
alright so we'll just be everything so
yeah yeah yeah for all times T I messed
up you you get K into the routine new
beers yes I'm on yes yeah
and these and here are a bit misleading
because we're adjusting for this because
like this K is like like this K is sort
of incorporating some other things into
here and so the end is actually gonna
bounce out to be the same but it looks
misleading and so in fact it says you
can now head like I'm every time step T
the static database what should I say QT
like I'm just hard time sort of so then
you were just set T equals n and then
you would run it once and you're done
yeah and so and so here we're gonna
start a time n for my databases of size
n oh I see yeah
and you know this is not epsilon-delta
right right we have a different version
that is epsilon delta actually the so
they like algorithm is the same but just
the analysis of it is different through
these different composition theorems
when you relax it epsilon delta like is
there an even better privacy law sir um
I think it's something like this K
becomes a square root K something like
that you have a weak or privacy
guarantee and huh huh
and then constants yeah yeah but that's
where is quantified how database is
rolling I think that yeah yeah yeah
and so imagine that I get one new data
point to each time and so and so at time
T I have a database of size T each time
you think yeah yeah I see so we tend not
just right you right
so you lose I mean their resort is sort
of K like D to the power of P right
exponential in T so but you lose square
root P so it's likely less than one day
I mean they just have like a fixed
constant T all right yeah I'm sorry but
I'm saying you lose like instead of like
monix resort I can think of ke to the
power of P but you lose you to the power
of each because they can answer answer
exponential queries at the same data
base I'm seeing at size n we are saying
we don't require or not so what they'll
say maybe that with error 1% you can
answer expression
yeah yes let's take a fine yeah hard to
expect yeah um cool ok so now let's talk
about like more general things it was
great that we that we can expand this
like very powerful private algorithm but
I might want to do more things than just
answer then just answer adaptive to just
answer adaptive linear linear queries
and so this part we're going to talk
about like a general framework for being
able to reduce in the dynamic setting to
the statics setting and so really I'm
saying I'm gonna like take it as a black
box some so I'm like private accurate
static algorithm and I then want to use
that has a subroutine in the case of a
growing database so I'll just solve the
same problem and so here's the like easy
case maybe I have like n data points
arrived and then I have K queries
arrived and I want to answer these K
queries on this database and then it's
really easy to see when I should run my
like static algorithm it should be after
I have enough new data and enough and
enough new i'm queries and i'm gonna
like plug that into my favorite
algorithm and rerun it great
but that's not how data growth actually
looks maybe maybe your data arriving
this very bursty way and perhaps you're
you're like I'm queries do too and so
like at what point should I rerun my
same static algorithm as a function of
my as a function of my have my growth my
database and of my queries arriving
online and I'll say again a time at time
T think of a database of size T and I'm
gonna have like one new point arriving
at each time step and so my T is gonna
count both both my time and the size of
my database okay so this is the same
accuracy definition as before but I now
need to define this somewhat strange
thing that's gonna be important in the
end and the analysis and it's a PG black
box and you're really just going to like
I decompose decompose my alpha guarantee
into something that that is that depends
on beta epsilon and and n raised to some
power P and then there's just gonna be
some garbage out front and to think of
this as some sound like a problem
specific parameters maybe it's a like a
dimension of my data
maybe it's my constants maybe it sound
like you know something like a convexity
parameter where there's gonna be some
like things out front and our privacy
and our accuracy guarantees are going to
depend on on this power P and so that's
why it's important we pull that that out
and so if we see a PG black black box
think of I'm just like a partitioning my
alpha into things that depend on beta
epsilon and N and then some other like
our problem specific parameters to make
this more concrete before I tell you the
more general vers
I'm going to show you a PG black box and
how you can like reschedule runs at this
black box algorithm has a function of
your data growth so we have the small DB
algorithm that was by a Blum like at
Roth in 2008 and it's a different
private algorithm for ik readings
pathetic data and so it takes in a
database X of size n and we have a data
we have a data universe of capital n and
a query class F and it's just going to
produce a database Y of size that
depends on log of my queer class over
over my desired alpha squared and it's
just gonna sample Y for the bias towards
databases that can like a closely
approximate my true database in terms of
my query class and so think of this as
like a non adaptive version of the pmw
algorithm how we have two like I specify
upfront all of my I'll have to like
specify upfront
do you like a query class that I care
about and I'm then gonna publish some Y
that gives me approximately correct
answers with high probability on that
and here's the and here's the like a
small DB theorem it is on epsilon
differentiate private and it's alpha
beta accurate put for this alpha this is
pretty ugly but let's now like I
decompose this into our PG black box so
P is our power and so we have log I'm 1
over beta all over epsilon squared to a
power one-third and so my power is
one-third and then I have like this
other stuff
the constant turns out to be 64 up to
this cube root and so up onyx I have a
power P and then I have some other stuff
that depends on my problem
and so the PG block box for these
parameters
and so let's and so let's see how we
might rerun this at various times as my
database grows so so really I'm just
going to rerun the same static algorithm
at different times at times TI equals 1
plus gamma to the power I times n for
some gamma less than 1 and I'm going to
each time produce a database why I
what's happening here I'm really just
going to like and I'm just going to like
I'm exponentially delay the runs of my
algorithm a mile exotic algorithm and
it's parameter beta or gamma tells me
tells me the base to that exponent and
so if I have gamma equals 1 then it's
like every time my database grows by
size n if it's sorry if it's if it is
zero that it's linear growth if it's one
if it's one if it's one that it's
exponential growth and so this game I
can sort of tune how quickly do I want
to rerun this algorithm as a function of
my growth and so I have this like
produced output stream y:i and i'm just
going to use that database to respond to
all the queries that arrive until I
rerun small DB the next time I mean the
key is this like is this sort of like
exponential delay and the optimal tuning
of on gamma and so and so doing this
allows us to work in a growing database
setting and things are basically the
same as before but I now have this one v
here is it of a 1/3 power power before
so this is sort of a concrete example
who wants to see the real thing go no.1
yes okay so here okay so here's the hole
so here's a whole thing I'm gonna walk
you through I'm gonna walk you through
each step but the key idea is that I'm
going to take a PG black box I'm gonna
rerun it at times could like
exponentially spaced out and I'm going
to get some accuracy guarantee that has
this loss 1 over 2 P plus 1 and power
compared compared to the same problem in
a static setting all right because
before I had this PG black box and so it
was G times this stuff to the power P
and I've just and I just lost in the
power a my accuracy that's it ok so
these things what is all mean so the
gamma is the base my exponent and notes
that it is independent of the data
growth and so this is just fixed over
time and this is the like exponent and
the delay like how often I should I
should rerun my fixed private acura
static algorithm and the Epsilon's we
tune them in each stage to make sure
that to make sure that our composition
gives us that adds up to our overall
epsilon guarantee and so I have some
desired epsilon and I just tuned this to
make sure that if I sum for all times
this is going to converge to be just
epsilon then the Alpha each time Ti is
going to be this and this is just the
accuracy guarantee you have a static
algorithm and so notice if I have a PG
black box this is just this is just the
Alpha that would happen naturally
I ran the algorithm at time t I and I
want to do the same thing for my betas
has I'm going to have this like
independent failure probability the head
each round and I just want my betas to
converge to sum over all beta so that I
could take em union-bound over that
failure probability and so although
there's like until though there's like a
lot of things happening it's actually
very simple I'm taking I'm taking a
fixed static algorithm and I'm going to
like and I'm just gonna like rerun it
two times that are appropriately spaced
out in terms of my data growth some
extensions of this in a paper are that
we give this like epsilon Delta
differentiate private version and so
here again we had this improved accuracy
at the cost of a slightly weaker privacy
guarantee we also give a hey a like I'm
different algorithm in the same spirit
then now has an accuracy guarantee that
improves over time and so this says that
my alpha is not to some constant but it
says that in fact my accuracy is going
to like approach perfect as my database
grows large and so this is appropriate
who do you think of problems for your
data are gonna be sampled iid and you
expect as you have it's like arbitrarily
large sample do you should be doing
arbitrarily well and so this notion is
more appropriate for those type of them
problems and this alpha T starts out
weaker starts out weaker to the fixed
accuracy guarantee but it becomes
stronger once the database roughly
squares in size and we also extend and
we apply this algorithm to the case of
empirical risk minimization where it
makes sense that if you have a larger
sample then you should be doing better
what time am I supposed to end
okay okay so then I will quickly just
like state stay at the results here I'm
not going to give the like erm
background and so if you know what this
will be cool if you don't then you can
take a mat for 30 seconds like the high
level addition of the previous results
like is it this one the theorem is
stated like you are this yeah yeah yeah
so takeaway is it is it really the loss
in the accuracy for extending a static
algorithm to the growing case just
depends on this power and so this is
like the only loss that you get it just
depends on unlike the original alpha
that you start with and this can also go
on forever and so here as long as your
database continues to grow then you can
like continue to answer queries about it
and you can still maintain the same
choosen intervals right once you fix
camera these intervals are also like
awesome
like maybe exponentially growing size
yeah and then are you gonna just apply
composition on it or is it no yeah yeah
yeah
because because the like static
algorithm says well with high
probability I'm going to be
approximately accurate and so as long as
you can take AME
union-bound over over those high
probability events forever
then they no still have the same like
high probability event they're going to
be correct for all queries forever as
long as you continue to accumulate more
data yeah yeah and also assumes do we
know nothing about like how this
algorithm works they don't have to know
like I'm specifics about it I I just say
hand me something that is accurate and
private and boom it now works in the
settings setting
like what if what if your database is
also like growing and shrinking like if
if there's data points that are now
being removed this is like a real-world
constraint that we see sometimes right
like is that is that possible like if
you gain ten data points because we can
never finish your oh yeah
yeah but that's actually a very good
question and like and like in two slides
I will talk about that to my open
questions because yeah because that's
very very real and like we acknowledge
that this is a one very specific type of
growth but those are lots of other like
types of changes that may happen yeah
sure that's that's fine anyways this is
my last like technical side so I'll just
sort of put things up there
so for applying this algorithm for the
accuracy guarantee improves over time
here's what we get for our empirical
risk and so here we have to have epsilon
Delta a differential privacy to get
meaningful composition and so if you
have d dimensional samples with high
probability for all times T you're going
to output a classifier that has like
excess empirical risk of this and
comparing that to the static case where
you have epsilon differential privacy
and feel like this is our black box that
we use as we apply this and we just
rerun this every single time and so and
so our like dependence on D and beta is
the same we have some loss because of
our Delta how we have like we have on
the bottom here we have like rooty
compared to their T and that's like the
only loss and so this says if you want
to do if you want to do here I'm
privately on a growing database this
works
pick your favorite static erm algorithm
and it will work in this environment too
and of course like once your T grows
large then you're going to be doing very
well
in the paper we also give like stronger
bounds if you have more assumptions on
the loss function like if it some think
if it some strongly convex then you can
do better as well okay so so the open
questions and I think that's actually
like really important because this is
one very particular type of growth but
there's there's a lot of other practical
types of growth as you put that point
out um and so here are like are like
various questions that I think can
follow from this that are basically
completely open how can you do better if
you have additional assumptions on the
data
um and so here we assumed adversarial
data growth in the worst case may be
data points are all sampled iid then you
should be able to do better how much
better I don't know um maybe they aren't
quite stable at IAD but their sampled
from some smoothly changing distribution
and so things that you have learned in
the past are still like mostly that
they're still like mostly correct and
you may want to like adapt them a little
bit more to accommodate for these smooth
changes how should you do that don't
know you also might want to like
identify when you have these like
dramatic changes in your data on the so
obviously I have a fellow paper with
myself
Sarek rebel yeah Jen may to array and
and wrong thing where we do like a
differential private change point
detection of seeing like you know I want
to like identify whoa the samples I'm
seeing now are like dramatically
different from things I saw in the past
and so this sort of like hairs nicely
with this how it's saying like is not
changing smoothly but it's changing once
and quite dramatically you may also want
to do some sort of like a be testing has
your points arrived online you want to
privately say
I think my a treatment and B treatment
are the same or they're not and there's
also like lots of other types of growth
that may happen for example you may want
to have some like changing data points
that can churn or can be deleted or like
or removed and that is not all accounted
for in this paper but that's a very like
practical and very real type of type of
change so that we see and there's also
this case of like I'm horizontal data
growth may deceive you and if you view
data as a matrix how I have liked how it
had like a row for each person maybe I'm
not just like accumulating new rows has
in this paper but I'm accumulating new
columns about the same people and that's
also not accounted for here but that's
also like very real and very practical
and so I think these questions are
completely open and very important in
terms of how it actually doesn't have to
be in this particular case and that's
how this case is like dramatically
different from from these two two cases
and it really boils down to this I'm
sensitivity of each query of being of
size being of public value one over the
size of the database and so as you get a
larger and larger a database each
person's data point matters less and so
you can sort of like naturally answer
answer more queries on a larger database
and so in some sense that's really at
the crux of all of these results is
we're saying
as long as your data grows faster then
your queries arrive then you're fine
forever
that's universe then you have all the
things yeah yeah yeah these guys these
are worse than what you get yeah and the
question is do they have to UM they have
to be yes because because if you're
gonna wait until until like I'm
everything arrives and you're just gonna
answer queries then then you're only
going oh no yeah yeah yeah yeah and if
you wait until the very end until you
how like everything arrived and you then
and you just then answer like all the
queries that's saying that your privacy
budget is going to be much lower
compared to if you had to answer these
queries a lot of times in the middle and
at the very end and there is like a
natural privacy accuracy trade-off how
the more queries you answer and the more
privacy budget to burn through
necessarily then your accuracy has to be
worse to compensate and so you see a lot
of these in the beginning you're like
the sensitivity of the queries is also
larger if there's gonna be one person
then of course if you wanna say than
your what you can change is much higher
than and so initially it was rapidly and
then yeah yes first best is just to wait
until you have all the data in the world
and you like I just answer queries then
but of course like that's sort of
useless as an analyst because you want
information
in the mean time and so this is saying
you're doing not too much worse if you
are able to like a continually answer
queries in the meantime in addition to
at the very end
executive yeah yeah had a lot of the
things in the privacy space they use a
term dynamic they mean the queries
arrived online and so it's like
adaptively arriving queries for a fixed
database and this is is more or less the
first work that considers dynamically
changing database like I think this is
your second point it's like only when
actually the solution changes I will
sort of and how many times my actual my
Instagram change yes yeah so that would
you can quantify in terms of that yeah
yeah I see what's that kind of mmm-hmm
and so I'll see this paper just said how
to like I'll find out when a change
occurred but it doesn't combine that
with these results which I think that is
also hoping it's like saying he's like
saying so I now know that I have
different data and I'm only then gonna
rerun these algorithms I think like I
quantifying how much better that is over
this case is sort of tied into all these
these questions
[Applause]
you